hey guys it's Justine and I'm here with
RO hello today we are about to unbox a
an easy bake oven yeah I thought this
easy bake oven and as you guys can see
it looks like it's been in a Dexter kill
room cover it all in plastic wrap just
round and round do you remember when we
baked in an oven before but it was like
a knockoff brand I was like that wasn't
gone great no no a lot of stuff happened
in that video that was fun now what I
had a great time it definitely a good
comment great but I not good wonderful
time and we're doing there to get a
little baking a little gadget testing I
haven't played with one of these in
years
well let's do it now okay mix the cookie
dough
one and Beyond fourth teaspoon of water
oh that's it
yeah that's it how is vaca no that's
like my drool like if I do roll it a
little but chip cookie mix and so wait
this is just put in here it yeah and I
got us these do I mix it now huh and
this is chocolate chip cookie chocolate
chip okay talk about a dumb monster
recipe oh my go ooh that is the pink
dough oh wow there's a lot yeah we're
making different colored cookies this
dough looks nice right I think that we
did a really good job I like the
chocolate chip cookie dough a lot it's
gonna be really delicious
what's this smells like a vanilla cake
mix oh it does yeah it's super simple
it takes nine minutes to bake that's
fast
who is how you that oh yes I don't
to be is that enough time I don't know
you don't even like that it's nine
minutes no I wouldn't want to go
instantly what about your info rent how
fast is that cook you can make cookies I
made dozens really we're so good he need
me make me a blue berry berry berry oh
and it has like a little muffin ton of
six and I made six and I ate all of them
over the course of like an hour yeah let
us know in the comments below what your
favorite muffin is it's better be
blueberry woooooo Barry I love like the
coffee cake with like the holes yeah
it's crumbly but you know what I'm just
gonna push it together and pretend it's
fine
its food but it's like fake food yeah
all right well we don't know what's
gonna happen
sprinkle flour on your hands and shape
the dough into 12 small balls this is
enough for one cookie they want us to
make 12 little more absolutely not so I
think this is happening is they want you
to make evenly they want you to make 12
of this and then 12 of that but I think
that we're we're not going to do that
we're going to make six and six I see I
think I made this too mushy now I'm
getting flour and that's really too
little just just a dribble that's a lot
like powdered sugar sugar flour you
honey already one little flour I'm gonna
need you here dip your little fingers in
there get a little flour there you go
and let's make little mini cookies
sprinkle flour on your hands and shape
the doughnut 12 small balls 12 small
balls let's just do six or just we're
gonna just see okay gonna happen space
them evenly on the baking pan one flap -
oh wow
[Music]
yours look great might look like turds I
only have one also let us know in the
comments below if Jesse and I should go
to Hawaii again we should cuz I think
the answers yes only by the time we post
this video and and I want to go on
another adventure our first adventure we
went kayaking we hang to a waterfall
Justine through it she flew a drone
right through my at waterfall landed on
a slippery rock she landed a drone on a
slippery I was very impressed
now I might've tried landing them I just
grabbed all this guy oh that's a good
call okay so we gotta figure this out
which I'm gonna stick it in it looks
like you this f this is the cooling end
no no I lied nice to get oh I think I
push it I think you eating I push it
over your hand push it yeah jam that in
there hey how smart when do I stop to
fart in here right okay I think it's in
there she met a timer for nine minutes
okay okay that means they have not yet I
know that you have a sous chef yeah I'm
serious
so great we have lemon frosting a hunch
Auklet frosting what's gonna go
well should we make both yes we're gonna
need I mean I have these poodles
I eat two bowls look at that it's two
words one
to powder free and I'm just because I
know I'm not
oh is this lemon or just vignette
supposed to be like oh I can smell it
now
lemon mmm I put too much water in again
alright this is a thick frosting I'm
gonna keep this one thick I smell cookin
I think it's cooking though I smell
something look it's more it's coming out
of these air vents oh it is actually
[Music]
okay here it is okay here you won't take
it out of there like a little pizza oh
that oh here take this don't burn
yourself don't burn yourself then will
my cookies I am impressed
they look like cookies whoa
that's cute this is really cute oh we
have to put icing on them look at him oh
my I made a really good job
mine too of mine stuck together I really
we supposed to spray the pan OOP no are
we I don't know I didn't want directions
I barely read them just seen if I
thought there's a fight down is it gonna
stick look yeah oh definitely oh no I
mean look at this you guys got it oh
there's sister Bob oh they're still on
the pan there's and it landed up right
so we're okay here everyone don't worry
but literally they didn't move maybe
they're still on there but we can touch
it I think it's a bit hot it's a bit bit
warm okay oh they're boiling here we go
get one
so we're gonna be able to get a cookie
out of this their cookies
alright let's buy some of these together
okay okay I'm gonna load it up perfect
look at that cookie sandwich just like
the box hold it up really close to your
eye okay it looks like we did a really
good job yeah this is the good side
don't look in the bag this is the good
side like a gingerbread house it had a
good side
do we try it yeah I think we should but
I want to try half yours
oh can you cut it in half yeah let's
what's up let's really just share I'll
give you the pretty side this one does
have a pretty side when we taste it oh
it's quite good after taste like a
cookie
oh look color me impressed Wow did you
try yours yet no okay here we go here we
go yours cheers the pink lemon cookies
[Music]
oh my gosh I seems really good I am
shocked I'm just gonna take a little a
little sampling okay okay I think is
good I'm actually doing a second bite
this was due this was actually oh my god
these are approved by me these are great
what why the heck does it so good I
don't know all right little cookies well
YUM here's the problem the Pam
should we make another one let's be lazy
moms okay let's just have a day where
we're lazy moms and we don't clean the
pan let's cook on top of it what's the
worst that could happen do you want to
do one more yeah let's do one more right
let's do this one cuz I think okay the
only one it's three bowls enough yeah
yeah I think because what's happening we
know more I have more is this is like a
refill unit so if you want to make a lot
of them like oven-baked parties yeah
okay great so for like all your friends
this is to bake for 16 minutes well I
know like that types teen minutes just
done well I think we need a spray I
think we use oh yeah let's spray it
spray we've got we've got spray we've
got spray okay here slowly okay that's
plenty
here's our oven I'm just gonna yep you
could bring over the oven thanks Justine
all right we've got the cake batter is
in the pan I refuse to let this come
longer than nine minutes so it should be
fine set a timer for 10 minutes good
call okay sprinkles boom I am your sous
chef today madam here is your one
tablespoon teaspoon teaspoon I don't
know I forgot I'm five
I'm gonna test the parsing oh that's
nice is it good what c'mon you yeah like
a funny taste funny taste that's nice
mmm yeah actually chocolate sides very
nice very nice mmm I think it's ready
chocolate chocolate come be my best
friend I got a hot me I got a meet I got
a plate right now is it cook is it
cooked
it looks cooked it looks pretty coolest
done this just looks like a truck Oh
Justine okay so yes we smash this
together yeah smash it up little balls
and then put this everywhere okay where
the sprinkles in there yeah poor a man
yeah we're gonna make we're gonna have a
cake Sunday this is our own recipe I
mean I need this but like we just need
it eat it right here stop this is it
this is dessert time
Oh tastes like a cake brownie and it
really does oh wow
whoa Wow I think crunchies too I like
this because this is like a substantial
amount I'm having another bite mm-hmm
I'm shocked I'm so happy right now
those stars for us today that's it mmm
we're gonna go eat this in private
this was really fun this was way more
fun than I thought I'm going to suggest
maybe we make something else in here
another day uh yes well guys make sure
you go check out roses channel I'll put
all of her links below yeah uh that is
that's all we've got for you today I
don't think I can handle any more so see
you later
[Music]